- It's time for my first guest everybody,
she is such a good person,
she'd probably rescue a
pig from a fire as well.
She probably has.
She's an Emmy, Grammy and
Golden Globe nominated
actress, singer, and songwriter.
She's killing it on This Is Us
and she's got two new
Christmas songs out now.
I love Christmas, I
cannot wait to hear them,
please welcome Mandy Moore, everybody.
(audience cheering)
(smooth music)
Hello, how are you?
- I'm well, how are you?
- I'm so good.
You look, okay this is my thing,
I get so jealous of people
that can wear turtlenecks
'cause you look so great.
I love people in turtle necks,
but I can't, I feel like
I'm being strangled all day.
- I can't lie, I must have like,
you know, some Diane
Keaton in me or something,
I just, I love a turtleneck.
(laughing)
- That is a Diane Keaton
thing, that's amazing.
Well we were just talking to a pig farmer,
so would you ever want a farm?
I feel like you would, you would be,
you would fit in on a farm.
- That story just completely made my day.
I was, I had to sort of stop myself
from getting too
emotional listening to it.
To have a farm one day,
you know, it's funny,
I, I'm a big hiker and I
was hiking Everest base camp
that trek in Nepal last year
and the higher you get in the mountains,
you're sort of surrounded by yaks
because they're the main
source of transportation.
And a lot of like the,
as, as you get like higher
and higher in the mountains,
it's like their source of food as well.
And so you have a lot
of like yak milk in tea
and you have yak cheese
and I just kind of fell in
love with the taste of, of,
of yak products.
- Yeah.
- And I had it set in my mind,
like I should open a yak farm,
I feel like there are no yak farms.
You can't find yak products anywhere.
- I was just thinking I've
never seen a yak or, yeah.
- They're beautiful
and obviously very strong,
but yeah, you, you have to
live in a very cold environment
to, to have a yak.
So those dreams were dashed for now,
but I don't know maybe, maybe
at some point later in life
I'll have a farm.
- I'm amazed, I, we've toured together,
like we've been around
each other a little bit
and I, I, I mean, I felt
like I knew you a little bit
like who you are,
but I don't think I had a clue
because you like, full-on skydive,
you don't hike,
you like you trek up mountains.
Like you do things that people like,
those are like bucket list things
and you do them like
regularly, like you love it.
I didn't know you were so adventurous.
- I feel like I've like come into this
slightly more adventurous streak
a little bit later in life.
I've been skydiving several times,
but the trekking and the
climbing and hiking has,
has become a new found obsession for me.
It's incredible,
but yeah, I--
- It seems therapeutic.
- I look forward to, it's,
it's so cathartic, it's so therapeutic,
I can't wait to do more of
it once I pop this baby out.